Right now I'm one hundred percent blind
and I think he doesn't stop doing his will,
which is for me because it's my whole life.
My house eats according to the tides and
everything around me is dedicated to
surfing.
My name is Aitor Francesena. I'm a surfer.
professional and I also dedicate myself to
teaching and I have been surfing all my life
[Music]
I was born with congenital glaucoma all my
life I have been struggling with not going
blind for 4 years I am left
blind I
was surfing and I fell in a
wave from above  down and with the eye open
and normally the eye
was still escaping they are half and
well in the end it happened doing what
I like the most which is surfing
the question that everyone asks me if
I thought I could surf being
blind well in  At first, if I'm
honest, not
until one day after I got out of the
hospital I went with a girl who was
taking care of me on the ig I'm going to try
surfing
[Music]
I put on some glasses and I realized that
the bad guy gave me a lot  there was information
in a classroom I turned to start rowing I
stood up and this can be done
and from that day until today it
has not stopped
but many of the ears the ears nothing a
lot of information to the followers they
give me the information of the  size of the
waves
very few times I don't get the sound with
the real size of what there is
a person who spends his life surfing
but I also gave myself teaching all my life
and before training in a
way that every time I saw something that  They did
n't convince me I took it out and gave them the
explanation and now that I don't see it I do it
differently
oh
what are you watching
we recorded the video and with the
video recordings I'm taking out the mistakes
each one doing their part you
can get to learn and  Getting to have
a very good technique is easy for me to teach in
this way.
We have also organized a clinic for
people who are in wheelchairs and
have physical problems so that, little by
little, more and more people practice this
sport.  surfing is so wonderful
in my life, every day is a challenge but
a wave in which you put on pieces
that forget all the bad things
here I want to teach all the people
who have a disability that with
enthusiasm and desire you can  do
anything in this life
[Music]